Even if we're having a discussion between sort of patient and doctor,
and the person seems to fully understand everything,
then the family or patient can walk away and 10 minutes later we'll have a discussion.
We'll say, did they say this or did they say that?
Like, there's big amnesia.
I forget what was said about the medication.
I can go back and see what medication,
and what the dosages and all the things that I'm supposed
to know are all recorded in that note.
Having it written down,
it's almost like there's another person telling you to take your meds.
I almost think of OpenNotes as closing the loop for me in many ways in that,
I meet face to face with the patient we have a conversation, I document it,
then I picture her going home and reading it later.
So it does feel like it extends the visit,
enhances the relationship, really sort of cements it in many ways.
It's actually allowed me to be more present in my visits,
perhaps ask some more thoughtful questions in
a moment because I know that that note is coming.
It's not just the conversation that we have for two minutes but they
have a document to back it up and to come back and to clarify themselves.
The second session that we had,
she said to me,
what do you think about the idea of putting our therapy notes into PatientSite?
I said, oh my God, I love that. She goes, why?
I go, because in my world I forget.
For me I go back to my open notes all the time.
My husband is very hard of hearing and so you can imagine, I mean,
even with perfect hearing I miss what doctors say sometimes,
and he's really lost so it's been a godsend that I can find out what the doctor told him.